the Joe Rogan experience yeah my Donna's
apparently coming back yeah yeah let's
go new I think you stopped then he
stopped together journey to fight and
then he stops again when did he stop I
don't know but I've read that he's
training to staff I and then he stops he
might Donna's it was room it wasn't
training with a Massey called Robert
Garcia yeah Robert Garcia Oxnard yes
yeah yeah wasn't training with him it
was training in Las Vegas somewhere so
we're training because it knocked makes
it look like it dropped loads away yeah
but all that Mayweather money way under
a postive all of his guns and cigars
yeah living the dream but anybody'd lost
Lord but then I read somewhere as well
they did stop the combat well well that
kind of lifestyle when you only have
like one chunk of money and it's just
sitting there you're chewing through
that yeah every day buying Rolexes and
Cuban cigars and next thing you know
like hey bro give me sweat suit yeah
yeah I mean he's not too old though my
Donna's probably 35 36 right now you
guys Chino Maidana it's not it's from
March it's not recent at all Oh real
good that's his last Instagram post
yeah that's why that's why I remember
looking at that I right after that the
commodes dorrance bones trying to
recently American so that's it huh go to
let me see what's going on before that
March the long ass time was good let me
see that that's what I want to see
before that but I want to see him hit he
looks thin there though that's that's
Maidana looking so much better than he
looked
I mean a year ago he was fast yeah
ridiculous like Bert Kreischer fat damn
he looks good I don't know why the
comebacks been well who knows man who
knows it's hard it's I mean when you're
out for so long to decide you're a
warrior again and you're
you know back to being a rational
athlete again like the commitment is so
significant yeah was that go before that
it's not that one that right there look
at that fat face yeah look at that face
he's so fat
that's a fat face he's odd you know when
you if I'd like to a free week off after
a tough fight yeah in that first couple
of week back getting zelf back into
eating clean in the gym everyday a game
back in a routine a bin laughs ooh that
that your cursors on right now look at
that that's what it's doing
yeah pimping smoking cigars drinkin yeah
but I mean how much money didn't make
enough Lloyd fights million yeah
baby-talking people demanded a second
one yeah he demanded the second one but
you know when he beat Barona down though
that was good good how many people went
yeah that guy is so it's it's so
interesting because he had so much
potential but for whatever reason he's
just like stepped on his dick sometimes
yeah well we got pretty goddamn slam you
got close dude but what is he doing now
cuz it doesn't say da stacks of cash
cheesesteaks having a good [ __ ] time
[Applause]